Now, I know from experience that at times
you can feel as if you're not making any
progress. You feel you've put a lot of
effort into it, you've been reading and
listening perhaps more than once,
reviewing your words and you still
forget them, and you still can't make
sense of what you're reading or
listening to. That's normal.
However, in order to make sure you stay
positive, which is so important ,you'll
remember the three keys, attitude is so
important, we have a lot of statistics
at LingQ, which show you that even
though at times you feel you're not
moving very quickly, if you see how many
words you've saved, how many words you've
read, the various statistics: learn... words
learned and so forth refer, to them from
time to time, because it's very important
to stay positive. There are moments when
you all of a sudden say "wow", you know "a
month ago I couldn't make sense of this
and now it's clear to me". But there are
other times when you feel as if you're
not getting anywhere, and that's where
it's so important to stay positive and
check against your goals and see just
how much you actually have achieved.